so for anyone who missed it there's a
lawsuit against activision blizzard for
culture there um i've had friends who've
worked there and haven't heard anything
about this
but the reality of it is it's jarring to
me
to see so many people on twitter who are
around the industry who are like gaming
fans who don't walk in the industry
go oh my god this is horrific
when my reaction is oh so it's normal
it's i mean not santa monica studio
where i currently work i feel like i'm
treated incredibly well i
i have had zero of those experiences but
even when i worked in tech before
the stories that i [ __ ] have just the
[ __ ] that they did to me like
like i was repeatedly like grabbed or
groped at work functions
and i would complain like to their faces
i'd be like don't [ __ ] touch me
and then they would be like
of course i'm so sorry i don't know what
i was thinking and then they would do it
again because me reacting to it
negatively was what made it funny to
them
so me going don't [ __ ] touch me leave
me alone stop touching me
is what made them go oh do it again
and so they would just keep doing it uh
people would try to kiss me often just
would kiss me without my consent
somebody like tried to put a shot into
my mouth
through their mouth and i was like i
don't want any of this [ __ ] so i went to
hr
and was like this place is [ __ ] up the
[ __ ] that's happening to me here
is super [ __ ] up and
hr sent out this email um and they were
like alana is uncomfortable at work
events
so they just blatantly sent out an email
and basically blamed me for my
own repeated harassment
after that happened instead of quitting
i just stopped showing up to work
i literally just abandoned that company
and never went back basically my point
there is just
you know i've had negative experiences
in tech
and and at games companies i feel like
i've largely been okay at
the places that i've worked but i've had
negative experiences both at ign and at
rooster teeth
uh either things that happened to me or
to other people that i supported them
through
to the extent that this actively
activision blizzard [ __ ] that like
watching my twitter timeline of people
who don't know
be like oh my god this is horrific to me
is like this is just this [ __ ]
industry
it definitely is a very big bummer just
whenever one of these stories comes out
it always hits i feel like every woman i
know who works in the games industry
sort of hard because you're like
of course of course that's that's what
happened of course somebody
took their own life [ __ ] sucks
like of course there needs to be
actionable change and this lawsuit i
feel like shines a light on this thing
but am i shocked or even surprised
not even a little bit it's a i think
like this culture of a lot of dudes
who
[Music]
were nerds and then got a really cool
job
and then now think they're hot [ __ ] and
deserve any of the women in their spaces
like the company i was talking about
there was a running bet
for who could sleep with me first i
didn't sleep with any of them
but there was a running like leaderboard
within that office
for which of the male employees would
get to have sex with me
like that's the culture of these places
on a global scale
they were like well we can we just have
to get a lot of drunk enough or like
coerce her in the right way or just like
push it hard enough and we'll see who
can do it first let's like put bets on
it like it was
[ __ ] like yeah i don't know and and hr
at any of these companies is generally
not very helpful because they try to
protect the company i
at one company um i didn't want to give
details of something that happened i
didn't feel comfortable doing so
um because even though something bad had
happened i was scared to
you get the person who did it in trouble
super complicated um and they were like
well we
might have to fire you for obstructing
company investigation then
and i was like you're telling me a
person who has dealt with something
negative that
i might get fired what
um it's just a [ __ ] nightmare across
the board it's basically my point here
and i'm not surprised about the
activation blizzard [ __ ] and it
surprises me that anybody else is
surprised
and it's really sad and there are a lot
of really great people in the industry
but yeah the bro culture
i think is what they call it thing is
like super prevalent if i were to ask
anyone watching this of anything it is
to
if you see something or you see someone
doing [ __ ] like that
like you know know that a
if the women who are being hit on or
whatever
laugh it can often be a sign of
discomfort that doesn't mean they're
okay with it
um but if you see this [ __ ] and you see
bros being bros and being like who can
[ __ ] the
this girl first just please [ __ ] say
something it's so much harder for women
to say something
it's so hard it's hard on every scale
it's also hard when it goes public
because if it does
then it's always being the victim she's
a liar prove it she was asking for it
well this is how she looks like that
shit's so vicious just if you see
a woman at your workplace being hit on
especially if it's by multiple men i
think that makes it a lot worse it's a
lot harder when there's a group of them
just be like maybe ask her if she's okay
and tell these people to [ __ ] off like
you have to help
if you also sit by the wayside and i'm
like oh i'm uncomfortable
i do think you're contributing to the
problem because you're not the one who's
at the height of discomfort please say
something
and be like this isn't i don't know that
saying this is inappropriate at the
workplace is going to help
but maybe even just a casual like hey
man leave her alone [ __ ] off
don't you have a job to do like just
something dismissive
because otherwise you can feel like
you're going through this stuff
completely alone
and it ends up at a lawsuit because
nobody internally takes it seriously
at all that's
my suggestion an ongoing thing not even
remotely surprised
more surprised that other people are
surprised
i also don't want like women to shy away
from getting into the games industry but
do you want to encourage any women who'd
be watching the stream who want to
to sometimes women see other women as
competition
like know that you're stronger together
like just talk to other women about it
it really helps
and i also don't know that
like boycotting these companies really
helps like i feel like that hurts a lot
of devs internally
they're gonna make money no matter what
i don't think i don't think that really
helps i think it's i don't know what the
solution for the public is when this
[ __ ] happens
it just is
pretty much everywhere in tech
so yeah if you see something
say something please from the bottom of
my heart please [ __ ] call people out
when you see them being even a little
bit creepy or too persistent
it's so much harder to do if you're by
yourself
but also don't [ __ ] tell people about
it that's a problem too is when people
go like
like if i go to someone in confidence
i'm like this is happening can you help
me and then they go tell someone else
and then you have to deal with this like
escalation of drama that you're like i
didn't want that i just wanted your help
you can't do that either just try to
support the people who are being
treated like [ __ ] because i promise you
the amount of [ __ ] that women in games
have to deal with
i mean especially for women of color but
women in games in general um
to also every single day you have to
deal with she doesn't
really like video games she's in the
industry for attention
she probably doesn't know anything about
video games the amount of [ __ ]
hurdles that you have to cross and [ __ ]
that you have to deal with to stay
you have to love it ten times more than
anyone else does
otherwise you just wouldn't be worth it
because it's it's just [ __ ] absurd
anyway now most of the [ __ ] didn't
happen to me you woe you like i haven't
dealt with like a
tremendous amount of terrible [ __ ] uh i
don't feel like i have at least well i
have had one very negative experience
but
um i don't wanna say i'm strong because
that dismisses other people i also like
generally don't care like i did have a
boss
who commented on my tits
and said some other creepy [ __ ]
and i was just like he's pathetic old
man
who cares like it doesn't i don't know i
feel like i'm so used to it
anyway just um
please please be actual allies not
people who just [ __ ] tweet stuff
please actually stick up for people
don't just put [ __ ] on your twitter
timeline
that's that's my request there